welcome to Hannity we begin tonight a
Fox News Alert get this James Comey I
hope he's sitting down for this big
breaking news only moments ago federal
prosecutors are now reportedly
investigating high-level leaks
classified material from the FBI and the
super Patriot himself according to a
reports is likely the target of a
criminal probe now remember only a few
months ago in an unrelated case the DOJ
Inspector General Orford call me for
prosecution over leaks and lack of
candor surrounding his communications
with President Trump now for more
trouble for Jim Comey we'll have details
analysis and more on this major story
coming up first tonight more
manufactured hysteria from the DC swamp
let me be clear there is absolutely
nothing significant nothing meaningful
about this charade this this miscarriage
of justice on Capitol Hill
you have conspiracy theorists con otras
and Liars say people that have been
doing it for the last three years they
are now dragging this country through
the mud and it's all out of pure rage
denial hatred psychosis and insanity I
want to begin with this monologue on
this point I want to ask everyone a
simple question you playing at home
answer in your mind's eye the question
and I really want you to think about it
since Donald Trump was elected in 2016
think what have Democrats what are the
media what are they ever done to improve
the lives of Americans now have they
done anything to create jobs prosperity
safety security peace well today's cover
the New York Post perfect representation
of what I am talking about on the one
side there you have presidents from
signing what many thought could never be
done a really great historic trade deal
with China 220 billion dollars in the
next two years alone this year next year
and that will impact the energy sector
the service sector manufacturing sector
our farmers benefit greatly two hundred
and twenty billion dollars that helps
the American economy and helps American
workers on the other
side of the picture there's Nancy Pelosi
smiling a dozen commemorative pens to
sign off on to bogus articles of
impeachment and then taking pictures
with yes smiles and Nancy's blatant
political stunts will improve the lives
of zero Americans it will add zero jobs
to the economy does nothing to make us
more safe or secure and we all know the
outcome it's gonna die in the Senate it
was just a few months ago that Angie
Pelosi said impeachment must be
bipartisan no Republican supported it
and then she rammed through articles of
impeachment in the house with the
support of only Democrats Pelosi also
said impeachment was so dire and so
urgent we got it pass it in record time
she then refused to send the articles to
the Senate for over a month a week's
long stall that almost no one can
explain Democrats that was after they
passed it so quickly before Christmas so
they can go on vacation for three weeks
don't forget by the way Nancy Pelosi
speaker a name only constantly reminding
we the people impeachment was her solemn
duty she'd want to do it she was so
prayerful and somber of course I'd also
Ally take a look so this is a very
serious matter and we take it to heart
in a really solemn way so sad so tragic
for a country December 18th
a great day to the Constitution of the
United States a sad one for America that
the president's reckless activities
necessitated us are having to introduce
articles of impeachment this is nothing
that anybody takes any satisfaction in
it's sad for our country this there's no
joy in this it's sad we must be somber
we must be prayerful sad somber careful
you want a pen you'd like a pen got
dozens of a smile for the camera we did
it so close he was so somber and
prayerful she gleefully handed the
special commemorative pens to her
smiling colleagues so they could all
take pictures together after signing the
articles all smiles a political stunt
born out of rage from beginning to end
now the Democrats charade continues in
the US Senate tonight they want to
introduce new BS evidence and charges
and material and witnesses that were not
part of the case remember the sole power
of the Constitution to impeach is in the
house they passed it already
now if a few weak Republican senators
try and help their radical Democratic
colleagues and allow them to call new
witnesses to do the job the
constitutional duty of the house and
enter all these new evidence guess
what's going to happen this actually is
a great thing I want to hear from zero
experience hunter by news paid millions
of dollars no experience
wow what a deal what company would ever
give you millions then you know nothing
about the business and then of course
we've got quid pro quo Joe let's bring
him in to testify you're not getting the
billion I should fire the prosecutor
that I know is investigating my zero
experience son and the fake hearsay
whistleblowers should be called to
testify but perhaps my favorite will be
calling the compromise corrupt
congenital liar Adam Schiff let's put
him under oath senator Ted Cruz and now
Senator Rand Paul vowing to trigger a
reciprocal witness list of any
Republican caves to the
Macross demands senator paul's
predicting no Republican will vote to
convict the president I tend to agree
with them except Mitt Romney I don't
know why Mitt Romney's angry
Mitt Romney hates Donald Trump every
second of every day meanwhile Donald
Trump is doing everything Mitt Romney
said he would do if he had got elected
president makes no sense to me